,
THANK YOU.
>> THANKS, JESSE.
>> Jesse: ANOTHER DAY, ANOTHER
SCANDAL FOR BLACK LIVES MATTER.
ONE OF THEIR RADICAL ACTIVISTS,
READY?
BEEN CHARGED WITH TRYING TO
ASSASSINATE A NAME NAMED GREG
GREENBERG, DEMOCRAT RUNNING FOR
MAYOR.
OF COURSE JUMPED AT THE CHANCE
TO BLAME THE ATTACK ON
REPUBLICANS.
A FORMER BIDEN CAMPAIGN STAFFER
TWEETING INSANE.
LUNATIC ATTEMPTS TO AASAN SIN
NATE.
CONSPIRATORIAL RIGHT WING
RHETORIC I'M AFRAID THIS IS
GOING TO GET MUCH, MUCH WORSE.
OF COURSE THE SHOOTER WASN'T A
RIGHT WING LUNATIC HE WAS A LEFT
WING LUNATIC.
QUINN TEZ BROWN IS A COP HATING
ANTI-GUN ACTIVISTS WHO ACTUALLY
AND ON JOY REID'S SHOW IN 2018
TO TALK ABOUT GUNS.
LISTEN.
>> WE WON'T GUN REFORM.
IF YOU ARE NOT GOING TO GIVE US
THAT, THEN WE ARE GOING TO GET
EVERYONE OUT HERE TO VOTE AND
WE'RE GOING TO VOTE YOU OUT OF
OFFICE.
IF YOU WANT TO KEEP YOUR JOB.
YOU KNOW, GIVE US WHATNOT WHAT
WE WANT BUT WHAT WE NEED.
>> Jesse: THAT'S NOT ALL.
HE POSED WITH AL SHARPTON AT AN
EVENT.
I TAKE PICTURES WITH PEOPLE,
TOO.
SO YOU NEVER KNOW.
BUT OBAMA, HIS FOUNDATION CALLED
THIS SHOOTER A RISING FACE IN
2018.
THEY CAN REALLY PICK THEM.
IF YOU THOUGHT A LITTLE
ASSASSINATION ATTEMPT WOULD
CAUSE BLM TO CUT TIES WITH
BROWN, YOU WOULD BE WRONG.
BLM LOUISVILLE SPRUNG 100 Gs
IN BAIL MONEY TO GET HIM OUT.
WHY DIDN'T THEY JUST PULL THAT
MONEY FROM BLM'S HEADQUARTERS?
THEY HAD LIKE 06 MILLION LYING
AROUND, RIGHT?
OH, I'M SORRY, IT'S STILL
MISSING.
WE HAVE SOME GOOD NEWS, BLACK
LIVES MATTER HAS TEAMED UP WITH
A GROUP OF PEOPLE WHO ARE GREAT
AT WORKING WITH SHADY CASH.
THE CLINTONS.
MINION MOORE A LONG TIME ALLY
AND CONFIDANTE OF BILL AND
HILLARY HAS BEEN PLACED ON BLM'S
BOARD OF DIRECTORS TO OVERSEE
THE MISSING MONEY.
THAT'S NOT ALL.
THEY HAVE CALLED IN THE FIXER.
YOU ARE JIMMY RIGHT THIS IS YOUR
HOUSE.
>> I'M MR. WOLF I SOLVE
PROBLEMS.
>> GOOD.
I HAVE GOT ONE.
>> THAT'S WHAT I HEARD.
>> THE WOLF HIMSELF HILLARY
CLINTON'S TOP ELECTION LAWYER,
ONE OF THE DEMOCRATS' DIRTEST
DIRTEST TRICKSTER MARC ELIAS.
THE UP WASHINGTON EXAMINER BLM'S
BOOKS ARE IN THE CARE OF THE
ORGANIZATION THAT'S LOCATED AT
THE ADDRESS OF THE ELIAS LAW
GROUP.
AND IT'S NOT JUST THAT ONE
FILING, MULTIPLE BLM REPORTS
LIST HIS FIRM AS ONE OF THEIR
ADDRESSES.
SO, WHO EXACTLY IS MARC ELIAS?
HERE IS A REMINDER HILLARY'S TOP
ELECTION LAWYER, THE SAME GUY
WHO PUSHED THE RUSSIA HOAX.
THE RUSSIANS HACKED THE DNC
SERVER BUT WOULDN'T LET THE FBI
SEE IT.
HE HAS WORKED TO UNDERMINE
ELECTIONs BY BURNING FOR
ELECTION LAWS TOES LOOSENED
RIGHT BEFORE THE 2020 ELECTIONS.
IS HE DEEPLY TIED INTO SOROS
MONEY.
MAKING MILLIONS OFF DEMOCRAT
GERRYMANDERING DISTRICTS.
HE KNOWS HOW TO SQUIRM, LIE, AND
GET WHAT HE WANTS BY ANY MEANS
NECESSARY.
SO HE WILL FIT RIGHT IN AT BLM.
JOINING ME NOW PROJECT 21
CO-CHAIR AND AUTHOR HORACE
COOPER.
HORACE, THERE IS SOMETHING JUST
SO TACKY AND PATHETIC ABOUT THE
CLINTONS SWOOPING IN WHEN
$60 MILLION IS MISSING FROM
BLACK LIVES MATTER.
IS ANYBODY SEEING HOW TERRIBLE
THIS IS?
>> WELL, FIRST OBSERVATION I
WOULD MAKE WITH MARC ELIAS IS
APPARENTLY AVENATTI ISN'T
AVAILABLE.
WHENEVER YOU ARE TRYING TO TAKE,
STEAL, MISREPRESENT RESOURCES,
YOU HAVE GOT SOME GO TO PEOPLE
ON THE LEFT SIDE IN THE LEGAL
ARENA.
BUT THE REAL TRAGEDY IS EVEN
PAYING ATTENTION TO THIS ABUSE
OF THE CHARITABLE LEGAL SERVICE
WAS OPTIONS THAT'S CALLED BLM.
WHAT ARE THEY DOING BAUSBYING
MILLION DOLLARS MANSIONS IN
CANADA.
OUT OF THE NORTH AMERICAN
REGION.
WHAT'S GOING ON, WHY DOESN'T THE
"NEW YORK TIMES" CARE?
>> Jesse: THAT'S INTERESTING.
LET'S LOOK AT WHY DO YOU THINK
THE CLINTON TEAM TOOK OVER THE
BLM CHARITY, MIRED IN SCANDAL
AND FINANCIAL SHENANIGANS?
DO YOU THINK IT'S TO CREATE
ALLIES BLACK MOVEMENT?
DO YOU THINK IT'S PERHAPS TO.
>> HA!
>> Jesse: YOU LAUGHING?
>> IT'S CASH.
>> Jesse: THAT'S WHAT I THOUGHT.
>> CASH IS KING.
AND THEIR GOAL AND THE REASON
THAT THEY BRING THEIR POWERFUL
INFLUENCE TO BEAR BEAR THEY SEE
A LOT OF CORPORATIONS APPARENTLY
DON'T CARE YOU ARE WILLING TO
PUT 20, 30, 50, $60 MILLION ON
THE TABLE INTERESTED.
IF YOU ARE NOT CONCERNED ABOUT
WHERE THIS $60 MILLION CAN GO
THEY CERTAINLY HAVE SOME GOOD
IDEAS.
THEN THEY CAN DOUBLE IT.
>> Jesse: THEY CAN.
AND, YOU KNOW, THIS BLM STORY IS
DISAPPEARING ABOUT AS FAST AS
THE WAUKESHA KILLING.
YOU KNOW?
BOOM.
OFF THE FRONT PAGES LIKE THAT.
>> I JUST WANT TO SAY THIS
REALLY QUICK.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW SO MANY
AMERICANS WHO ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT CRIME ARE IGNORING THE
FACT THAT NEARLY A DOZEN PEOPLE
WERE KILLED DURING THE BLM
PROMOTED RIOTS OF 2020.
AND NOW WE HAVE MR. BROWN
HIMSELF, AN ACCUSED MURDERER OR
ATTEMPTED MURDERER, AND WE ARE
BAILING HIM OUT.
WHY WOULD THE CLINTONS OR ANYONE
ELSE WANT TO BE ASSOCIATED WITH
THEM IF IT'S NOT FOR THE CASH?
>> Jesse: YEAH.
I WONDER HOW JOY REID FEELS, YOU
KNOW?
ONE OF THE GUESTS ON HER SHOWS
IS NOW CHARGED WITH ATTEMPTED
MURDER?
HOPEFULLY NO GUESTS ON "JESSE
WATTERS PRIMETIME" HAS BEEN
CHARGED WITH ATTEMPTED MURDER.
BECAUSE I WOULD BE DISTANCING
MYSELF VERY QUICKLY.
REAL QUICK.
>> JESSE, I THINK SHE -- I THINK
SHE IS GOING TO HIRE THE FBI TO
INVESTIGATE HOW THIS GUY, AN
ACCUSED KILLER GOT INVITED ON
HER SHOW.
THAT'S WHAT SHE DOES WHEN SHE
DOES HATE TWEETS.